okay it's 11 40.
i guess we get started i spare you the
usual intro of how sad it is we can't be
in oslo right now
it is very sad especially since we all
can't go to the dubliner tonight
so you know um so let's just do this um
from the same chair that i'm sitting in
now for the last 12 weeks you know i got
older
longer hair glasses all that but
um very exciting topic for today right
it's about openly connecting all of them
security best practices and
um before we start with that uh just um
one thing i will upload those slides
directly after my talk i
didn't have the time to do it before
that's what i normally do
i i will upload them and you see that
basically it's going to speak attack.com
lease privilege that's um where i upload
all my slides so
maybe the archives are interesting as
well but i will upload this particular
slide
deck right after my talk okay
good enough about me uh why are we here
so i've been actually working for the
last
two or three years where um for the
norwegian government basically
to introduce um over and over the
connect into the
health uh system so they're you know
getting rid of an old system
decided to go for token-based security
and
for over openly connect and for identity
server which is nice
um so but as you can imagine especially
in healthcare
um there are so many laws and special
regulations and rules and so on that
the the plane oauth as it is in rfc 6749
yeah is it's not enough you need you
need a more secure profile
of these protocols to tailor you know to
cater for
for these industries and um so we've
been working on this um
profile um actually another industry
which has similar needs the
the banking industry is working on a
similar thing called sapi
for financial apis and we in the health
system
uh are working on happy which is for you
know health apis
um and it turns out that uh something
very similar in parallel happens in the
states
for uh you know like government and
enterprise
of two profiles so um
[Music]
basically what this this talk
is is an excerpt of a trait of training
material i've been creating
for the last six months or so which
talks about
basically security best practices in
auros
and um and this new thing called over
2.1 which we'll
talk about at the end and then the
second
talk which is later today i think at
three o'clock uh is
think of it as a as a um as the part two
of this talk
where we talk about um new specs
that are either partially done
or already released that help you
improve the security of an existing
oauth deployment
so these are all the topics and they are
from from this new training i just um
launched a couple of weeks ago and
that's way too much material
so i will you know pick pick for this
talk and for the next talk
just the things that i think you know
are the ones that you
must hear about okay um
one word of caution right if you're
gonna start learning more about this you
will ultimately
deal with documents that look like this
right
um it's uh you know the fun stops here
right it's a career fund
um uh you get um
uh you know this funny funny ascii art
um for example um things like this
right um and you know
um even clicking this pdf link will not
make you happier if you don't like
that format because because it looks
exactly the same
um as as the website
right um but you know
actually it turns out for the newer
specs they now have nicely formatted
html versions of that
um so if that is easier on your eye
totally fine
but you know one of the reasons why this
is the way it is is basically because
you know you can read it with any
browser so you know if you just
use the the very first browser ever
created right
you can basically
basically um you're saying you're seeing
only powerpoint
is that correct and no
no console window oh okay well
then let's go back to powerpoint anyways
um not so important um we only need
powerpoint for the rest of the talk
um but yeah so my point is um
okay you see the console well
man you totally derailed my train of
thought now
okay uh forget the console um
anyways we go back to powerpoint so
um anyways my point was um this talk
we'll talk about
the first at the other half which is
about um common attacks common counter
measures
you know security best practices and so
on and then the second talk will pick
out some of the topics
from the you know when you go beyond the
oh of 2012
once back but let's give you some
context first
um so when we look at the timeline how
things are happened and why they
happened you know like
we go all the way back to 2005 where
basically
that was the birth if you want of
web-based authentication right like the
the fundamental pattern that
you're authenticating a user you're
sending the browser to some place and
that
some place calls you back with something
like tokens
that is all being you know it goes back
to the demo 2p protocol and then
ws federation protocol and ws trust for
more like um
um for more like um
um you know web service style
communication
um that was very enterprising you know
xml and so on
and uh shortly after the the consumer
space discovered the need for
token-based protocols as well right i
mean fundamentally just this was the
time
um where you know like uh you
you've suddenly had new scenarios where
a third party wants to access your gmail
account but how do you do that without
exposing your
google password to the third party so
they came up with this thing called over
1.0 which you know is basically a talk
uh
a protocol for requesting access tokens
to access
resources where on behalf of um
uh a human being typically um
over 1.0 became uh very very
uh popular and um a couple of years
later you know like all the big
companies jumped on it you know like
microsoft and you know like all the
enterprise
people that before that were rather in
the saml and w star space then i wanted
to
shape the future of oauth and
that ultimately became over 2.0 and
one of the themes in over 2.0 was like
simplifying the protocol
because of 1.0 had a lot of crypto going
on
um and they simplified it to a point
where
people were unhappy about the security
that got lost along the way um so for
example
the thing called bearer tokens um was a
new thing in oauth 2.0
that didn't exist before and is arguably
less secure than the proof of possession
tokens they had before
and maybe you heard about the history um
and um and um
that the spec author left the you know
left the itf
uh like with a big bang and made this
final talk about olaf and if you're
interested in seeing that
talk and why he left just search for the
word you know your favorite swear word
o off okay you probably find it
um anyways um part of the legacy of this
spec offer was that he demanded that
there was
you know like a the um that the token
usage should be
specified separately so that shortly
after we could come up with a
proof possession style of token usage
never happened
until just recently and we'll talk about
this in the next talk
um but also
the other thing was that they created
the threat model for oauth because
the problem is that o of 2.0 has so many
variations and
uh you can even if you follow the spec
do an insecure implementation of it
because it gives you so much room
for interpretation or variation i guess
yeah
so they created this threat model right
from the start
and made sure that this got published at
the same time as the protocol itself but
the threat model to be honest is it is a
bit theoretic because
a it was created before we learned
really how people will use obor in the
future
um and you know since we didn't have the
real world use cases it was rather
you know as i said a bit theoretically
looking at the various uh threats and
risks and
countermeasures and so on and so forth
um so in other words it
it is interesting for security
professionals but not very
actionable for a developer for example
because there are no there's no concrete
guidance in there
yeah anyways um lots of things have
happened
many protocols have been built on top of
the oauth 2.0 specification
it became more popular right and um
at some point people said like well we
also see security problems with with
over
we we need more guidance yeah and uh the
very first
guidance document was published in 2017
it's called over 204 native applications
and it's
what they call a bcp a best current
practice right and it's um it's good
that the word current is in there
because the older the document gets the
less current the guidance is of course
but
this is pretty still pretty good and it
gives you concrete
guidance about like if you're writing an
android app do this if you're writing an
ios app do that if you're writing a
windows desktop app
you know do that um so
basically the idea was let's let's give
people developers
implementers more actionable guidance
to secure their oauth installation
so and then more pcps have followed
there's one which got published last
year which is called the json web token
bcp
which talks about how to securely use
json web tokens um
and if you see that picture that's five
years
after json web tokens got specified yeah
and
a couple of um new ones will be
published this year
um the most important being the security
topics bcp which is
which is basically think of it as the
the version two of the thread model but
this time
much more practical and there's one
which many people have been waiting for
is the browser-based
um um bcp okay
and you know in the future soonish
there will be over 2.1 and we'll talk
about what this is and then
in the more distant future there is
something
currently codenamed over 3.0 um
which is you know which will still take
some time
okay so what this talk is about
basically give you an overview of the
most relevant things of the documents
you're seeing here
and as i said um you probably you
probably need um
need more time and and follow these urls
and
have a better read because as i said i
can only
give you an overview in 60 minutes and
it
you know there's much more to to reading
okay so just a big picture right so um
um
a token-based system pretty much looks
like this right so we have front-ends
you have
back-ends and you have back-ends for
back-ends and you have different call
patterns and different client types and
you know
you want authentication and you want api
access and you want single sign-on
and you want delegation of identity to
back-end services
uh you know all the things right and the
security token service is the abstract
thing that
that is like the traffic cop in between
that issues the tokens um and that's
where you implement openly connected
so to simplify this a little bit yeah it
basically always looks like this
you have um a human being
maybe um but you definitely have a
client a client it is a piece of
software that wants to access
a resource yeah which for all practical
purposes typically is
um an api um the client cannot access
that resource directly it first needs to
go to the authorization server
and ask for permission if you like and
that gives them a token
and with that token they can access the
resource server and we basically have
two types of clients one other more like
the machine to machine style clients
where
no human being is present and the
the other part would be the interactive
clients
like a web application or something like
this a native app
where a human being is present and
authorizes that line to access those
resources on this behalf
yeah so if we wanna look at the security
properties or rather the risks of such a
system right
we have to look at the attack model and
see like what are
the attackers that potentially you know
would attack this system
so um i've i found the cheesiest
possibly cheesiest um symbol for and for
an attacker for a hacker right so excuse
me
um but um the first type of attack is
basically
we say when an attacker can read or
write unprotected network traffic
man and that that's an easy fix for that
right you have to use tls for everything
the specs are not always clear um but
um it's pretty much you know a known
thing
that you have to use tls for every
single network indirection
if then an attacker can still access
network traffic well then your tls
infrastructure is compromised
or even worse maybe your dns is
compromised and that is a serious
problem that network people need to fix
but nothing that we as developers
can do so that's not our our our problem
basically the other um the other
uh attack that is not strictly speaking
the the problem of the oauth or openly
connect
implementation is if an endpoint gets
compromised and
with that we mean unrelated to oauth or
open id connect yeah maybe
on the server there is i don't know like
a um
a telnet endpoint which is unsecured or
uh a cross-scripting attack or a sql
injection attack something like this
that is you know
not related to the over end points but
still allows an attacker to take control
over remain
yeah again um not our concern
at least not from the point of view of
this talk right i mean it is definitely
our concern but
not for for the protocol
what definitely is a protocol concern is
if an attacker can mount additional
endpoints and that to be honest is the
most
interesting part these days uh because
attackers find creative ways to
use the system in a way that you haven't
foreseen it so what if for example an
attacker can mount
a rogue authorization server or if they
can mount a rogue client or a rogue
resource server
and that gets even more exciting i guess
if they can trick the legitimate client
to use the rogue authorization server or
can trick the legitimate user to use the
rogue
uh client with the legitimate resource
server you know like all of these
permutations
um that you know are probably
legal protocol interactions but uh
executed in a way that you have not
thought about it or have not protected
yourself
against right um i'll show you an
example later of that which is um
which is brilliant if you think about it
um but also
devastating yeah um the good news is
is that by far the most attacks just
happen because of
plain programming mistakes yeah so the
the the
by far the biggest group of um attacks
are basically
where the attacker can read but not
modify the contents of the authorization
request or response
now and that might be enough to
compromise the system
if they are clever enough right and that
might happen because you are leaking
data
because you might have open redirector
attacks because maybe
um you're leaking data into the browser
history into proxies into log files
something like this right um the good
news is they can all be fixed
these are just you know knowing the
right keystrokes you can fix them
and and can solve the problem but still
um by far that's the biggest group
of problems we've seen in the past
okay so these are basically the the
adversaries that we
try to protect against um now
these these security guidance documents
have been in the works for quite a while
no one was
taking uh you know paying attention to
that um
until i guess that is late 2018
um one of the authors torsten
lauderstadt which is a well-respected
colleague of mine um
wrote this blog post you should stop
using the o
of implicit grant and he
basically said like if you do it you
might you know this might result in
attacker accessing your health records
or initiating a payment from the bank
account
and to be honest you know um the way it
was written
it was a little bit you know
so the next day i got emails from
customers or on twitter or
you know basically people thought like
oh have you read this blog post they
found a new vulnerability in oauth
and that is of course not the case
he didn't find a new vulnerability in
oauth he just said
that from all of the ways you can use
oauth the implicit trend is the most
problematic and that was from the start
known and if you have read the threat
model it's in there
yeah all of the problems with the
implicit grant
were written down from the start and you
know just to recap why this really
exists was
that back in 2012 they were looking for
a way to give a javascript-based client
easy access to the oauth protocol and
remember in 2012 it was not possible to
use ajax calls
cross domain because we didn't have
course by the time
yeah so they found a way or hacked up a
way whatever you want to call it
that allows you to basically uh you know
do everything
um on the query string parameter so you
send the request over the query string
and then you get back the tokens over
the url
back to the client and as i said this
was a workaround because in 2012
cross origin ajax calls were not allowed
and um we found many many problems with
this approach because
leaking is is easy here right it's on
the query string it ends up in the
browser has to read ends up in logs
and so on so long story short in 2020
we totally solved the cross-origin hx
problem
um so there is no need anymore to
transmit tokens over
uh urls okay it's error prone
it is hard to secure um we should not do
it anymore
which doesn't mean that if you are doing
it
right now and you implemented all the
right counter measures you have a
problem
yeah all i'm saying is it is a very
risky way of doing things which is not
necessary anymore
okay so first takeaway don't use
implicit flow anymore if you have
existing ones
think about rewriting them i mean which
is not a rewrite of the app but
just changing the protocol flow okay
while we are at
um deprecating
flows the next one that is not
recommended anymore at all is the
password grant right
the password trend is this flow in oauth
where you harvest the credentials of the
user in the front end and then send them
to the back end
to get a token back um the main problem
is that
the user types in the credentials into
the client application and not
into the into the authentication server
users should be educated to only type in
their passwords in one place which is
the
system that owns the account right
um and research shows that the more
often you type in your password into
different places
the more prone you are to fishing
attacks so
avoid that as well if you can also
the password trend is not compatible at
all with modern authentication methods
like fido you know two-factor
authentication acceleration
and so on many of the popular
commercial authentication systems don't
even allow to use that anymore
okay so that's another thing you should
think about okay which basically is
a good thing yeah because if you look at
all of the different flows and
variations
we had like one year ago yeah um
depending on which type
of application you're writing you had
like uh
many choices right and many choices
means you have to understand
the different uh you know uh uh
uh um properties of all of these choices
and and their um
you know um uh advantages and
disadvantages and so on
which basically became harder and harder
now with um with the new work and
looking at the system
with a bit of um you know a hindsight
it's actually nice that we can shrink
down our options
which means that you need to know only
two flows
really which is the client credential
flow
which is for non-interactive
applications like server to server style
communication
and it's the code flow with this little
extension called pixie which i'll show
you in a second
so all the others basically um wherever
a human being
is involved which dramatically
simplifies the learning curve
and less options gives you more security
okay let's have a look at machine to
machine first
so machine to machine
basically you know it's pretty simple
you have the client
you have um resources or apis and you
have the authorization server
the authorization server knows about all
the clients about all the
apis it knows about which client is
allowed to access which api
so the client goes to the authorization
server authenticates with the
authorization someone says hey give me a
token for
you know api one or api two and
if that is allowed the authorization
server returns
um an access token back to the
to the um client and then the client
will use that access token
to um to call to contact the apis
now um some some things we
we can't cover here but i still want to
mention them is um
access tokens have been unspecified by
overwatch itself
right so in when you look up the
original um of rfc
there is no um mentioning whatsoever how
an access token should look like
what's the format what's inside what's
the semantics and so on it just says
there is an
access token and that is what gives you
access to the apis yeah
there's a lot going on in in that space
um
especially since i guess the industry as
a whole decided like that chasing depth
tokens
is the the preferred the preferred way
to do access tokens right
um so if if you look at
or if you are using json web token as x
tokens you should definitely have a look
at the new json web token
bcp um which talks about you know like
what are the
the best practices in in which crypto uh
you know algorithms you should allow um
how you know like um common
vulnerabilities that we found in
in in json web token libraries the good
news is if you're using the microsoft
chasing the token library
um then you are you're good
yeah and this one is not vulnerable to
any of the
known attacks um also that there's a new
document
uh which you should have a look it's
called the json
it's the json web token profile
for oauth and this kind of like tells
you
or gives you a common language if you
like how to use chasing web tokens in
the context of oauth
which which claims should be there what
what are their names what are their
formats
what are the semantics and something
yeah so that is something that you
definitely should have a look at
um another thing that
definitely you should revisit in 2020 is
how do clients authenticate with the
authorization server
and um you know it's a very common
practice to have shared secrets right i
mean that's just one step
up from the api key that many people
were using
um shared secrets are easy easy to get
started with right um
they sound easy to use to begin with but
they are a bit of a management
nightmare right i mean they are shared
that's the first problem yeah so
how secret is a secret when it's shared
um
they have to be you know there's a
metric so they have to be
at both the client and the server side
um
they should have a high entropy right um
you should not store them
um in reversible encryption meaning you
should
you should hash them on the
authorization server just in case that
if somebody
is able to breach your configuration
database or system
that they don't get you know all of your
client secrets in clear text
um configuration management is a bit of
a problem
um they need to be transmitted or the
wire right that's another thing what is
what if the network you are crossing is
untrusted
yeah um so potentially the network admin
of that network
you know like has access to your clear
text secrets in in
in proxies things like that so you know
they are a bit problematic
asymmetric keys instead solve many of
those concerns right because there is no
secret anymore to store on the server
side because it's just a public key
the secrets don't get transmitted over
the network
um you can attach
other properties to it like expiration
of secrets or replay detection
of secrets um and in the next talk
uh this afternoon i'm going to show you
uh basically a way to fix that using
um a technique called private key
chasing web tokens where
you basically xj you know replace that
symmetric key with a with a
a client generated chasing that token
which you know solves many of these
of these problems yeah the other thing
we're going to talk about this afternoon
is how to solve the bearer tokens
problem right
um i mentioned that earlier um that one
of the
concerns with uh overvisits is that the
tokens are not bound to the client
meaning you know if you are you know
it's it's like cash
right money when you lose your money on
the street and somebody finds it they
can use it right then there's no binding
of the the banknote to the owner of that
banknote
um unlike credit card for example yeah
where there is
a certain binding there you know in real
world might not be as strong as we want
but still there is something like a pin
maybe or a you know like a signature or
a picture something like this yeah
um in oauth up until recently we didn't
have that they are all token to the
bearer and if they leak
somehow over the wire anybody
especially you know the bad guys could
use could use them to call the apis
impersonating the
original owner yeah um
that is uh you know one concern from
calling client
to server but that might be also a
concern if
maybe you are leaking that token to a
malicious
server right maybe you're calling the
wrong api with that token
and now this api has that token and then
called the legitimate api instead
right and the legitimate api doesn't
know the difference
so again um that is
something you should consider um
uh especially if there's a chance of you
know again leaking
or you know tokens being used in
weekly secured clients or maybe tokens
traversing
untrusted networks there we can make
this stronger and again i'll show you
techniques
for that um in the next part this
afternoon
okay let's have a look at interactive
applications they are the far more
interesting target for attackers because
they are easier to attack
because there are humans involved yeah
and these humans um not only humans but
also browsers yeah and browsers are
as you know um i mean browsers are very
powerful they are very useful because
they can show a ui
and they can follow redirects right the
problem is that browsers can also show
uis and they can follow redirects and it
might be the wrong redirect to the wrong
ui and the user might not be able to
distinguish that right
so since the whole browser-based
interactions are based on sending people
back and forth
these back and forth things are very
interesting targets right so just to
summarize that how does
a browser-based flow work basically you
send the user region to the
authorization server the authorization
server shows the ui to log in the user
to you know maybe do consent and these
things
and then the uh authorization server
sends back
a so-called authorization code and then
the
client application opens the back
channel to the authorization server
hands in the codes
the client id and the client secret and
gets back
the tokens and from that point on the
client can then you know a authenticate
a user and b
um call apis on behalf of the user
now as you can imagine these two
redirects here they are
the the main target right so let's have
a look at
attacks that um specifically target the
redirect uri
okay um so
the original oauth spec did not did not
make any statement
um how how you should validate
these urls going back and forth to do
the redirects yeah
the threat model did and also the over
money connect specification did
um they say um you should never ever
have any sort of
variables in there right um like you
should do a strict
uh exact string matching even case
sensitive yeah
and the reason for that is basically
these
callback urls they are very very
sensitive on that
url you are running your very security
relevant token validation code for
example
um and if you um you know and
the better you can isolate this code
into a single place
the better the moment you're allowing
variables like this here star dot some
side or some side slash star
you are opening up the attack surface
basically where tokens can be sent to
and potentially there's a bug on this
url
that allows leakage forwarding open
redirection
things like that okay so you should
minimize your attack surface by only
allowing a
single callback url or at least as
a very specific set of
particular callback urls and not give
the attacker
a chance to do to insert star okay let
me give you two examples of things that
happened in real world with these
approaches so last year i think it was
um
electronic arts ea that um
had a subdomain takeover attack and uh
the way this works is basically in in
short works is let's imagine you know
you are creating a new a new application
you go to azure you register your azure
web app it gives you foo
at azurewebsites.net right and then you
write your application and at some point
somebody adds a dns entry to that
so that this full thing becomes part of
your dns namespace yeah
so yeah so ea had billing.ea.com
and that was an allowed target
for a token so it was an allowed
redirect uri
okay all good so far
but at some point the billing
application was moved to another part so
they shut down
the foo website on azure websites
but forgot to remove the dns entry so
now suddenly you had billing.ea.com
pointing to a non-existing azure website
and you know you can query the dns
server and find out that this is the
case yeah
so what the attackers did was they
registered
foo dot azure websites again because
that was free
right and suddenly billing.ea.com was
pointing to an attacker website which
was able to a
execute code or under the ea domain and
b
was a valid redirect uri now for tokens
to leak them to
an attacker controlled site okay um that
wouldn't have happened if they would
have been very strict with the redirect
uris
and i guess yeah i mean you know these
things happen but
uh you can't have a defense in fear by
being more explicit
the other thing that happened to for
example facebook and also github is is
this here
like allow site slash star for example
facebook allowed for a long time
that the redirect you arrived to be any
page on facebook and i think github had
exactly the same problem yeah
so if that's the case you know what
attackers would do basically is they
will find
some page underneath that domain that
has a problem yeah
maybe it's an open redirector maybe he
can check content yeah
so in the case of facebook what happened
this is that um
what the guy did was he created
handcrafted um
an authorized request and pointed to his
own
facebook page as a redirect uri and send
it to friends right
so they clicked the link they went to
facebook they got single sign on
the token got the code got created and
got sent
to this guy's facebook page so far
nothing
dangerous right i mean people were
seeing the facebook page they were
thinking like what what's going on here
um but that was
a bit clever than that yeah so what he
did was on the facebook page itself
he posted an image that came from a
server that he controlled yeah
from his own server and basically now
what happens is you know imagine uh
the browser goes to the facebook page in
the url there's the authorization code
coming from the authorization server
the browser sees that image it makes the
outgoing
network call and on the referral header
the browser puts the current url
which includes the code okay
and that means now that the code got
leaked to a server
that was under control of the attacker
so the attacker only had to
look at his log files in the web server
log files and harvest
those codes and now turn these codes
into tokens
brilliant i mean uh hi you know i highly
respect
the the guy that found out how that
works yeah
now you might think uh but what's the
problem with leaking a code right i mean
didn't we just say to turn a code back
into a token you need a client secret
absolutely right you know um for for
confidential clients in oauth
a client secret is required to turn a
code into a token
but is that really stopping attackers
there's another attack which is you know
became
more popular is it's called
authorization code injection
and the idea is yes absolutely to to
turn a code into a token you need to
know the client secret
but what if you can trick the original
client application
into turning a stolen code back into a
token
using its own secret well what
is that good enough yes and it turns out
it is good enough so imagine
um an attacker is able to steal an
authorization code using any of the
techniques we just talked about right
leakage redirect uri tricks whatever
yeah
so now he has a stolen code but now what
the attacker can do is hand craft
the callback url um
open the application himself the
legitimate application
and craft the url insert the stolen code
and then send it to the client and what
will the client do
he will happily take that stolen code
with the client id and the secret and
turn it into access tokens
these access tokens are not available to
the attacker directly but the attacker
is now locked in as the victim
into the application and can do whatever
the application can do and
i guess that's in most cases that's good
enough okay
so yeah authorization code injection is
definitely possible even with cold slow
so how do we fix that well there's
another thing called roof key for code
exchange pixie yeah as many people call
it
and the idea is with pixie that you are
introducing a per request
secret um that the attacker cannot know
and basically uh proves that the client
is the
same client on the front channel and on
the back channel so the way this works
is basically
is is that the client creates a secret a
random number
and hashes that random number which is
called the code
challenge and then he sends the hashed
version of that
over the authorized request um and then
the authorization will you know will
store that
hashed version and then when the code
comes back on the back channel
the client will send the clear text
version of that secret
and now the authorization server has
both the hashed version and the geotext
version
he can hash the clear text version and
if they match
the client has proven that he is the
same client on the front channel
as it is on the back channel okay
now in our injection scenario if the
the attacker does not know the original
so
the client that the attacker uses to
hand in the stolen code is not the same
client instance that was used in the
first place to leak the code
so then you know the the the code
verifier doesn't match
so the authorizator will uh reject
the request and that is how you solve um
uh injection attacks okay um
a similar attack um which is just the
other way around i guess is um
is uh is basically by um by using uh
leveraging cross-request forgery
where the attacker pre-creates a
legitimate code
right and then and then basically uh
creates a callback url sends that to
victims and tries to force them into the
same logon session
by them handing in a code that does
belong to a different
log on session and that is very similar
to a session fixation attack
back in the days when we had you know
session ids on on query strings
right uh again same thing can be fixed
with pixi
um if you cannot um enforce that pc is
being used that line can
on its own um implement counter measures
by using the state parameter
in in oauth where basically the idea is
um
that the client pre-creates uh the
decline creates a secret stores it
locally
puts on the state parameter and then the
authorization must echo back that state
parameter
and then the client can check that the
secret
that he put in here is the same
and correlates to the request and since
again the attacker cannot know that
secret up front
clients can detect that whatever
callback they just got sent
does not correlate to any request they
made in the first place
um so the recommendation is to do both
implement pixi as well as do the the
anti-sea surf
um technique yeah with the state
parameter
so that you know you have a little bit
of defense in depth
okay so that's basically um that that's
the overview
you know always do exact matching of
redirect you arise
um make sure your callback pages are
locked down as possible always use pc
use the state parameter
uh and you know like it's for example a
very easy way to fix the
referral problem is by using referral
policies or use the normal
you know attribute for example so that
the browsers don't generate them
okay let's move on to something more
esoteric maybe yeah
that's um what we call a mix-up attack
and a mix-up attack has a couple of
assumptions here
may uh the first assumption is is that
the client trusts more than one
authorization server and that was maybe
back then right in 2012
not really a common thing but today it
is very common right log in with
facebook log in with google
or maybe you have a federation gateway
in your company that trusts
multiple external providers so
um that's that right so that's the the
prerequisite you
you you trust multiple providers and
maybe
for somehow you have a self-service
portal that that allows users to
register their own providers again think
of software as a service scenarios
and one of those external providers is
evil okay
it's an attacker authorization server so
for this for the purpose of this um
uh illustration here we have two
authorization servers one is the honest
as and one is the attack arrays yeah
so imagine you know the user selects the
honest as to log in
and now this this variant of this attack
has
one assumption namely that the attacker
is able to manipulate the http traffic
maybe it's a browser extension maybe
it's something in javascript whatever
but basically the point is that the
attacker is able to on the fly
change the selection from the honest as
to the attacker ias
so the client application will think
okay he selected the attack arrays
let's send him to the attacker as now on
the way back the
attacker again is able to modify the
traffic and switches it back
to the honest as so the browser will
actually go
to the selected authorization server
okay so the user will not see any
difference um
now he will authenticate and so on and
so forth the
authorization tool will send back the
authorization code the code will go back
to the client
the client still thinks that the
attacker is was selected so he will
happily
send his code and his sequel and so on
to the wrong
authorization server so all of that all
of all the as now needs to do is
basically take that client id secret
and code and he will be able to get the
access tokens
okay so that is what we call a mix-up
attack
basically because the client mixes up
the
the two um authorization servers now
this has the assumption that the
attacker can modify network traffic and
you might be saying
well if that's the case i have bigger
problems
yeah yes but let me show you another
version of that
where this is not necessary okay so
that's another variation of that
and this time the user selected the
attacker as to start with so you know
maybe if he clicked the wrong button
maybe
the attacker ais has a logo which looks
very similar to the thing that he really
wants to
select whatever right he's he clicked
he chose the wrong authorization server
okay so far so good um now we are the
client sends the
user to the attacker as right yeah
attack ias knows well
he he doesn't expect to come to my place
so he immediately forwards
the browser to the real to the honest as
by rewriting the client id
and the redirect uri so now the user
will see the real
authorization server with the real login
page and so on and so forth
he will log in then the honest ais
thinks that is a legitimate request
coming from the
client and will send the code back
to the client right but now the client
gets the code from that
attacker af thinks sorry for from the
honest ass
things the attacker is has been used and
again sends the code and the secret
to the wrong place and now the attacker
can turn them into
tokens okay so that's an example of
um when i said like mounting additional
endpoints
gives us very interesting attack
scenarios so
um yeah if you're not prepared for that
um this is a pretty interesting attack
the good news is yeah if you're using
asp.net core
then you are secure by default and the
way they they prevent the mix-up attack
is by giving each
external provider a unique name and a
unique callback url
okay and what they do basically when
they
generate the authorized request you see
that they come up with a random number
which they call the correlation id
and they encrypt and sign that
with the data protection api in asp.net
core then drop a cookie
which has the format of correlation dot
authorization server name
dot correlation id which is the random
number they just created
okay now when the response comes back
on the uh authorization server specific
callback url um the protocol says that
whatever is on the state parameter must
be sent back
so this contains our encrypted and
signed correlation id
so what they do is basically they
validate the signature
decrypt the value and now have the clear
text correlation id back and now they
make sure that
there is a cookie called correlation dot
authorizations have a name dot
correlation id
and if that cookie doesn't exist somehow
there's a mismatch between the thing
that the start of the flow and the thing
that
uh finished the flow and they will
reject that and maybe you've seen that
before there's a an exception called
correlation failed
that can happen for other reasons as
well but that's how they stop
basically these mix-up attacks okay
so um so if you're using 8. core
are fine if you're using any other
framework you should have a look how
they
implement um protection against these
types of attacks
okay um
so let's switch gears for a moment and
look at uh public clients yeah like uh
um you know like things like mobile
applications or sparse yeah
uh public lines have slightly different
rules right i mean you cannot
authenticate them in essence because you
know
it's a public client they cannot store a
secret so you cannot rely
on any uh you know client authentication
like we can do for
confidential clients yeah um
[Music]
so let's have a look at the first
anti-pattern that the bcps point out
especially for native
um client applications which is native
login dialogues right
so it's a very common thing and you know
that that
the native application brings up its own
login page where you type in the name
and the password right and if you are
unlucky
you have a really good password and you
have to type it in now on your phone
um and then they send that to the token
service get back to token and so on
so this is using the the password cran
that that i mentioned earlier that is
now deprecated
and shouldn't be used anymore right i
mean yes i know
you wouldn't believe how many hours of
my life i wasted with product owners
discussing
why this is bad um you know they say
like it's my client it's my user it's my
back and
what are you telling me yes i cannot you
know
i cannot force you to do the right thing
but
we know that this um
is not the best way of doing it you
should rather
let the user type in the password in the
place where your account is stored which
is on our authorization server
which means you have to open a browser
to show the login ui
which i think is the better way of doing
it but that's just me
that gives you support for password
managers and for all of your logging and
auditing
and your advanced authentication methods
and federation
and all these things right and because
you are using the system browser here
you potentially get single sign on as
well with um
your whatever you are logged on to
already in um on your machine or on your
phone
right um so that that's the that's the
recommended way of doing it
so use the system browser every
operating system has a way of doing that
right
the mobile ones are a bit more advanced
here because they give you
a better ui or ux rather
to show the browser put the browser away
again on desktops you probably seen that
before it's sometimes a bit weird that
the browser opens up and suddenly it's
in front of the application and so on
still these things can be fixed um
and then you have to figure out how to
do the callback from the browser back
to the application there are a couple of
ways of doing that
again i would recommend reading that
document because you know it has
all the details but the best way of
doing it is what they call claimed or
universal
urls and you probably have seen that
before right
when you open a link on your phone to
google maps
and ins instead of the browser that the
app is opening
on the phone um so
there must be some way of knowing that
this url belongs to that specific app
and the way this works is basically that
you're dropping on that url
a special document which is signed uh
which tells basically the
the operating system that hey
if if this app is installed on the phone
rather
forward that link to that app otherwise
show it in the browser
that's how you can implement the
redirect uris
for native apps which is a very elegant
way of doing that okay
um token storage is always a concern and
we talk about that in
in a second in the context of
browser-based applications for native
ones you have the luxury of
well not storing them in the browser i
guess you also have access to
native operating system apis like you
know the keychain on ios or dp api on
windows and you can
put additional things on top of that
like face id or touch id
or things like that um also
you know it's a good idea to clean up
when you're done like
revoke refresh token that logout time or
when the application uninstalls
and so on and again uh you'll find more
of that good information in that um
native apps pcp the last pcb i want to
talk about is the browser-based ones
which is you know
a sad one i guess because we just can't
fix those browsers it's
it's it's a lost course right um
but ultimately right the main problem
with browsers is is that they
are shared execution environments they
are just like you know these days a
little bit like operating systems here
with every tab running in different
processes and so on
but one thing that is still share
typically are cookies yeah between
you know because that's how the bed
works i guess um
but the interesting observation is that
many attacks i start with the word cross
right because it somehow one side
attacks another side
and that is due to the nature of this
shared execution environment now
this is a topic for a whole day i guess
but we all you all know that there are
basically two fundamental ways to write
spas these days one is you're relying on
browser building features
like cookies or the other one is that
you're driving it from the application
like access tokens um the cookie
approach
historically has cross-site request
forgery problems the token approach has
historically cross-site scripting
problems yeah so
it's a bit of a you know um
choose your poison i guess here
if you look at these pcps they give you
two fundamental ways
how you can think of javascript based
architectures
and this might sound backwards because
for many
years now this was the style that was
advocated by javascript people with
javascript application without a back
end right
basically the this stream of you can
just download your js file and your html
from a cdn
no backend needed we do everything in
the application
yeah very hard to secure
in this scenario that the client has to
do everything
request the tokens manage the tokens
store the tokens and that's the hard
part
you know uh and you know to do the live
the lifetime management and so on
um the more you know coming back
more and more people are using this type
of architecture which i
personally recommend as well which is
basically that you have
in addition to your spa a back end that
belongs
to the spa that stores the tokens
manages the tokens calls the apis on
behalf of the spa
which means no tokens stored in the
browser which means you know cross-site
scripting cannot exfiltrate them
and you know i mean there are many
arguments going you know
back and forth but i think this is the
easier threat model
that's my personal opinion which
basically brings you to such an
architecture here right
uh which which some people call backhand
for front end or bff
where you have the front-end which is
written in whatever javascript framework
you like
you have a back-end for that which has
the local apis which are
application-specific
you can use an external identity
provider you can call external apis
but the point is that the front end
always talks to them
via the back end and they live on the
same
site right and then you secure that
front and back and connection
with either and defaucery or if
you can with the new same site cookies
which is a new
feature in browsers and if all the
browsers that you need to support
support them as well then you don't have
to write any
line of code to secure them because the
browser automatically takes care of
making sure that these cookies don't
leak
across side boundaries yeah and you
probably remember
there was some drama around that in
chrome chrome 80
chrome 80 yeah introduced um
basically made every cookie same site by
default which broke
many many websites right and then they
realized oh we broke the web and oh it
was during a pandemic so they
they undid those changes again now they
are back in chrome 83
so yeah that's the future every cookie
on the web will be same size by default
unless you opt out explicitly from that
um and you know that's just the way it
is
um if you don't like that cookie
business and you have to store that
stuff in the browser well then be
be aware of that there is no secure data
storage in the browser
right everything is available from
javascript which means
if you have a cross-site scripting
attack it the tokens are available to
the attacker
you can harden your applications right
using for example content security
policy um
and you know just basically scrutinizing
all of the additional libraries you're
pulling in from npm
um but yeah there's that right
um for the for the session management
you have to make up your mind how do i
wanna do the token management there are
two options here one is using
session bound techniques which are
getting harder and harder these days
because of things like intelligent
tracking prevention in safari and you
know brave has the same thing now and
more browsers are coming or you do
refresh tokens
yeah refresh tokens are even more
dangerous in the browser because they
are typically longer lived and there are
some some techniques that you can apply
to them for example rotating the refresh
token
detecting replay attacks and so on but
these are things that you have to
implement on top okay and again
i can only recommend if you are writing
spas read these documents
they are useful to read okay
which brings us to our last topic over
2.1
so for the last
57 minutes i talked a lot about
documents that uh
add rules to o
of 2.0 okay so
the so in other words if you today
want to learn about oauth you have to
read the base specification
then you have to start reading all the
bcps and the threat model and then you
merge all of these documents in your
head
and that's basically what you need to
know right
so the idea of oauth 2.1 is basically
to start with a new baseline and the
whole idea is this
we are taking the base specifications
which is rfc 6749 and 6750
merge them together then we take all the
various pcps i just mentioned and merged
them together
and that becomes o of 2.1
which is the new baseline for
o wolf and um if you want to div them in
your head
basically the most important changes are
this implicit grant is gone
password trend is gone pxe is mandatory
for the authorization code grant
redirect uris must be compared with an
exact string match
no knows you know no regular expressions
allowed things like that
um refresh tokens must either
be sender constrained meaning that they
are used by confidential clients and the
center constraint is done by client
secrets
or they must be one-time use only which
is primarily targeting
public clients like spas where you know
basically every refresh token user
should result in a new refresh token and
that you can detect it if somebody
starts using the same refresh token
twice which probably is
then an attack man all the bearer tokens
must not be
um sent anymore using using the query
string
uh for the for the reasons i mentioned
they leak too easily you know
um
log files uh proxies and and so on
okay so that's basically that is coming
soon um it's it's it's not done yet
2.1 it's i'm i think it will come this
year
but that's these will be them the big
changes
okay so to summarize that
um you know uh
some some some of the threads we talked
about cannot be mitigated like you know
network compromise
some of the threats are easy to mitigate
but just you know following the rules
like you know do
anti-seizure protection uh close those
redirectors you know
and so on and some threats will always
be hard to mitigate even if you have a
perfect implementation and i'm mostly
talking about things like
you know like the mix-up stuff and if if
an attacker specifically targets your
system and they find the things that you
might not have thought about
well even with a perfect protocol
implementation
there is some room here right um
as a summary i can say you know
sometimes i i
talk to customers and they say like you
know what after you told me all these
things
we don't want to use oauth it sounds
very complicated and insecure
um and all i can say is every security
protocol
is complicated right and
because it must be you cannot solve
a hard problem in a simple way i mean
you can simplify things but it won't
it never will be simple um the the
beauty about
oauth is that it's public it's open
source and it's
it's um publicly tested
and attacked and iterated on and
by using a standard you get basically a
a
a a protocol that many people have
worked on that many people have tried to
break
and if you come up with your own
protocol then maybe you are the only
person that worked on it and you are the
only person that
tried to break it and maybe you didn't
succeed and you think oh that must be
good
so all in all you know um
yes oauth is complicated ish
um but i think it's still the best thing
we have today
cool thank you um if you have any
questions you can speak up now or
leave a question in the slack channel
i'll try to get to that
otherwise i guess it's lunch time thank
you bye